mr. list very good morning to you good
morning according to Boris Johnson
Jeremy Corbyn has let down his party and
his country by eating the Russian
propaganda machine I mean in what way is
that helpful actually forget that and
what way is that true well I think many
people who saw what the leader of the
Labour Party said on Monday were
surprised I think some of his own side
were disappointed the way he reacted and
certainly when he went and continued
that position on Wednesday and actually
I have to say across the house I think
what is important across the House of
Commons there was unanimity and support
for the position that gum has taken in
position the Prime Minister has taken
where the real focus has to be on giving
some confidence and security and
thinking about the safety of people
particularly obviously people in
Salisbury but how is that letting down
the country I mean that's just
jingoistic nonsense isn't it mean that
the situation as initially described by
Theresa May was pretty clear either the
Russian state was responsible for events
and Salisbury a Russian criminal gangs
who had somehow acquired the now have
agent now as I read things this morning
the situation still exactly the same as
described by Theresa May isn't it yes as
trees were may the Prime Minister's
outlined herself that's very clearly
where the evidence points and we made
the point to Russia and asked Russia to
respond to that and we saw as the Prime
Minister outlined on Wednesday we didn't
get the sort of response we would have
hoped to have got and it's right that we
do and the Prime Minister's absolutely
right on Wednesday to outline a series
of actions in order to make sure that we
do the right thing by the people of the
United Kingdom and also working with our
partners internationally to work to get
a good international agreement around
how we go forward because this is
something that can affect any country
anywhere if that evidence is correct as
you just said there is no fresh
intelligence that implicates the Russian
premier of the Russian state as opposed
to Russian criminal gangs sort so again
I asked this question because language
is important in times like this in what
way is Jeremy Corbyn let down the
country by condemning events and souls
but it in the strongest possible terms
and pointing the finger of suspicion at
the Russians well actually I think what
you're look back what the point the
Prime Minister was making last week and
the point that the agencies have made is
that this point the evidence points
towards
Russian state and if it isn't the
Russian state directly than it is
arguably because they have lost control
of nerve gases and their system and
therefore there is a responsibility for
the Russian state and that's what it's
very clear the Prime Minister's point
was asking the Russian state to respond
to this in a proper way that is
internationally acceptable and also from
our point of view of course protecting
the safety and security of people in the
United Kingdom
I mean mr. Lister I'll note that once
again you are studiously avoiding the
point made by Boris Johnson that Jeremy
Corbyn has in some way let down the
country with the response that he gave
in the House of Commons I mean look at
the questions that he asked of Teresa me
many of which frankly I would have asked
myself if I'd had the opportunity to put
them to easily after our statement you
know what action is being taken with the
OSI PW can the Prime Minister outline
the discussion she's had with NATO EU UN
their willingness for a multilateral
action that's letting down the country
what discussion has she had with the
Russian government that's letting down
the country well Ashley I think if you
look at what happened in the House of
Commons both on Monday and Wednesday
last week was labor back bencher after
labour by venture backing the prime
minister and there was a very clear
distancing between themselves and their
leader and actually even some of the
front benches some of their comments
arguably I would say stepping away from
the position and the the manner in which
the leader they were party Jeremy Corbyn
made his points and the prime minister
was very clear actually that she has
been and he's continuing to work with
our international partners including
NATO and others and obviously as we've
heard this morning we've got the
chemical weapons being assessed and the
international agencies looking at coming
to this country tomorrow to look at that
but it's very clear where the evidence
points and that's why it was the point
was made that it is right that the
Russian state should respond to that in
a sensible way to support and help the
work that we are doing on this and we
didn't see that happen and that's why
the Prime Minister took the actions that
she did on Wednesday that she outlined
to Parliament yeah again mr. Lewis I'll
know that you haven't been able to point
to any of the questions asked by the
leader of the Opposition after all after
to resume a statement as inappropriate
or in some way you know traitorous
treacherous letting down the country
actually the point the point made by mr.
Corbyn which caused the most
consternation on your side of the
chamber was when he said well he asked
the Prime Minister whether or not she
thought it was essential to maintain a
bust dialogue with Russia in the
interest of national security I mean we
are maintaining a robust dialogue
Theresa May agrees with Jeremy Corbyn
Minister easily letting down the country
today I think if you look at the
response we've seen this week is
highlighted in the way that she has
dealt with this situation exactly why
she's such a good Prime Minister for
this country she I think she has dealt
with this absolutely superbly and the
view of the British people seems to be
one that absolutely concurs with the
fact that she has taken absolutely the
right action both fast nashi and the
work that she did when she's been in
Salisbury herself and she has made the
point that we need to continue our role
within NATO because there are issues
around the world where we need to work
with their NATO partners but that
doesn't defer from the fact that we need
to take a very strong position around
what seems to be and a foreign States
action on our territory and we
absolutely have to make the point that
we've got to make sure that the security
of the people of this country comes
absolutely first and central I did make
the point in answering your previous
question in fact more than once that if
you look at the tone in the way that
things were discussed in the House of
Commons it was clear that there are
members of the Labour Party this is a
matter for them it's not saying for me
to come home that would take a very
different tone in position to that of
their leader and I leave that for other
people to take of you about what to talk
about talk I mean isn't the truth of
what Boris Johnson was doing when he
suggested that Jeremy Corbyn had let
down the country what what you're doing
right now is all of a piece with that
idiotic defamatory Street sent by Ben
Bradlee in which he said Jeremy Corbyn
sold British secrets to communist spies
I mean you mr. Johnson have clearly
learned a lesson you're not going to
have to make a groveling apology you're
not going to have to make a substantial
damages but you're all making the same
point well actually I think there's a
really important point here if you look
at the tweet of Ben Bradlee mate which
he himself except he was a mistake and
before anybody forced him to do so he
deleted Italy then ippolit no no no he
deleted that very very quickly he also
apologized and yes he has had to pay a
substantial sum to charity but we do see
things coming from the heart lifts and
indeed just last weekend from Labour MPs
that even when they do deleting they
don't apologize they certainly don't
make donations to charity I think
there's a vast difference between a
statement that was made that's been
apologised for and reparations we made
to some of the social attacks and
actually the abuse we
of people from people on the hard left
often on social media which is
completely unacceptable it's why we as a
party have said that for these local
elections which are policy in the next
few weeks we will have a respect code
and if our candidates don't abide by
that we will deal with that and we will
suspend them it strikes me that you
don't realize just how dangerous this
type of language is I mean the rhetoric
you choose at a time plan you know three
people have come very close to death as
the result of the deployment of a nerve
agent I mean isn't what mr. Johnson said
of Jeremy Corbyn isn't it awfully
similar to what the Russians say about
Sergei scribble you know that he's
failed the country that he's a traitor
well actually I think what the Foreign
Secretary was outlining and as I've said
several times over the last few minutes
is if you look at what was said and I
would encourage your viewers to go on to
Parliament TV and look at what was said
in the House of Commons both on Monday
and on Wednesday by people from right
across the house and the overwhelming
support the unanimous pretty much
support but it seems to be with the
exception of the labor leader was for
the position and the actions taken by
our prime minister Theresa May I think
she's doing absolutely the right thing
and I say I would leave people to look
at what was said look at the manner in
which it's been said the way that the
labor leaders conduct herself and I
think they can draw their own
conclusions why was it wrong for mr.
Corbyn to point out that the
Conservatives had accepted over 800,000
crowns from you know some pretty dodgy
looking people and companies with direct
links to the Kremlin despite the fact
that Theresa May had promised to
distance herself from Russian donors why
was that inappropriate well because
actually these are British citizens we
absolutely abide by all of the rules
that donations have to go and they all
fully declared they're in the public
domain and actually these are British
citizens many of whom would have
actually potentially fled Russia because
they do not support the Russian and
States position and president Putin's
position and somebody's a British
citizen or a British company does have
the rise of British citizen and we
should defend their right to play a full
part in British society and we should
sort of Teresa let me just finish young
Don you're missing a very key point here
we are we only accept donations from
properly approved donors who are who go
through due diligence obvious from our
British written Minister mr. Vyse that
are on
you sanction and all of these have do
diligence there properly declared they
are in line with the Electoral
Commission and let's be very clear
these are British citizens and this
issue is not an issue as the Prime
Minister self is very clearly said where
we have an issue with the Russian people
and certainly not Russian people have
come to this country made their lives
and become British citizens this is an
issue with the behavior of the Russian
state as it seems to be from those
actions just about 10 days ago 160
thousand pounds to play tennis
with Boris Johnson a hundred and sixty
thousand pounds did to play a game of
tennis it doesn't the widow of Alexander
Litvinenko marina have a point when she
says that these donations were
calculated it certainly it certainly
looks that way I mean she certainly has
a point when she says that you know
Theresa May has failed and her promise
to do all within her power to ensure
that there wouldn't be a repeat of what
happened to her husband no absolutely
the Prime Minister was quite right in
what she said and if you look at what we
are doing and the changes we made
through the criminal Finance Act to the
Prime Minister outlined last week in
taking forward some changes and
amendments in law going forward and the
use of unexplained well-thought as this
is a government that is dealing with
that kind of criminal money and it is
absolutely what we do so but there's a
very separate issue we shouldn't confuse
the two things all political parties
raise their funds they do some of that
through fundraising events and we do
only take funds from British citizens
and there is a big difference between
the Russian state the Russian people and
of course people who are British
citizens but just to be clear as party
chairman you're telling me today that
despite two reason a promising to
distance herself from Russian donors
you'll be more than happy to take their
money in the future I'm absolutely clear
that we only take money from people who
are British citizens British resident
bye-bye all of the walls of the
electoral commission and it is
absolutely right that we do not stop
British citizens from having the ability
to fully participate in British society
and that includes perla politics as well
Brandon Lewis many thanks for joining us